in this video want to look at how people
search and put it in context of your
advertising efforts so that as you make
decisions about how you're reaching
users you can make sure that it's the
correct decision based on how people
search people do not use search engines
to browse the web people use search
engines to find answers to their
questions throughout this lesson I'll
describe how search advertising steps
away from gimmicky advertising and
instead helps users answer their
questions use a psychology of search to
your advantage by helping users find
answers especially when that answer
results in an order for your product in
this video you will learn to describe
how people use search engines to find
answers explain how ads help users
answer their questions list situations
when advertisers should refine their
targeting explain how an advertiser's
relationship with the searcher differs
from an advertiser's relationship with a
search engine and express why search
advertising functions as informational
advertising so we look at users overall
we do not use search for is to browse
the web that your social media or
newsreaders are for so we really use
search for is to learn the answer to a
question there's something you don't
know and you want to know it that's when
you turn to a search engine now people
though we just don't think in words so
we have to type words into a search
engine as users we think in concepts
there's a few steps that you
unconsciously go through before you ever
start searching so the first thing is
you have this concept of something you
want to know and then you've got to take
that concept and translate it into
actual words this list leads to a lot of
unique queries out there on the web in
fact one of those fascinating numbers
you'll ever hear is that while Google
processes six billion search queries a
day twenty percent of them
have not been done ever before or at
least six months of time so there's a
lot of unique users we're trying to
reach with search so it was a user every
time you do something you have an
expectation of results something you
expect to see so when you put in a
search query and you look at the results
if they're not what you expected to see
you're going to refine your search query
before you ever click on something we do
some action we have an expectation of
what's going to happen afterwards so you
type in words in a cert tension you have
an expectation of what that page is
going to look like what the ads organic
listings are going to be now if you look
at the page that's what I was expecting
to see this looks like the concept and
the answer that i'm looking to get more
information about then you're going to
really start digging into the listings
and look at the ads and see which one
can probably answer your question now
that's the searcher from the advertiser
perspective this is often your first
brand interaction with someone this is
your chance to say hey look at us look
at what our offer is come to our site we
can give you the answer which is an
advertiser takes that searcher and makes
them a customer so if someone looks at
your ad says I think you can answer my
question they're going to click on your
ad and go to your landing page now this
is industry jargon landing page is the
first page of your site someone sees
after clicking on an ad know when this
landing page tells a user this is how
you get the answer or this is the answer
itself that's when you get customers so
for instance it's a buying guide how to
buy a new plasma TV just put the
information on the page but the query
maybe I want to buy this specific TV and
therefore the actual action that occurs
is the process of buying it or they have
to call you up on the phone to get the
answer this goes to your goals as an
advertiser overall but when you look at
your landing page and ensure that the
message you put on the page answers the
users question or tells them how to get
the answer
when you get better conversions from
your search efforts and so it's
important to note that search marketing
is not interrupted marketing if you're
watching television use watching some
show and you're enjoying the show and
then a commercial comes on and all of a
sudden it interrupts which you're doing
and so you may fast forward through the
commercial you may flip channels that's
an eruptive with search someone's
actively looking for an answer they're
trying to find information and so as a
marketer when you treat search as a
channel of answering questions and as
you answer questions you get customers
for it that's when search marketing is
really powerful now there's a lot of
times though you don't want to answer
the question right this gets to refining
your audience so for instance there's
certain words so may search for that
doesn't really describe your product
where you may have certain users you
don't want to show ads to because you
don't ship to the area we don't service
a specific area you may see that your
conversion rates are great on desktops
but not on mobile you might exclude
mobile users or maybe you only answer
your business phone from nine to five
you don't want people to click on your
ads at midnight so our times then that
you can refine your targeting and decide
not to answer questions because it's not
a great time for you and so when you
think about it your ad tells the
searcher you can answer it if that's the
goal so this dictates then what you
should put in your ad it also lets you
know what you should pay so by looking
at how often your ad is clicked how
often someone becomes a customer user
analytics you can decide then how much
you want to pay for those clicks a nice
cyclical process so as you're doing
search marketing and you're riding your
ads with your analytics you have to
direct people with certain pages on your
site so you should always look at what
page can answer the question this isn't
often the homepage if someone searching
for e-commerce product you want to use
the product page they're searching for
how to get the cheapest insurance in
Chicago you want to use a Chicago
insurance page and so look at the
keywords look at the ads pick a page
that meets that expectation that
increases conversions now if you don't
have a page like this you may need to
create some pages to ensure you're
always relevant to the user and then
once you have this data in place you've
got your keywords you've got your ads
you've got your landing pages you will
get customers so then paid search gives
you so much data you have to track
conversions when people become customers
when they're calling you filling out
your forms contacting your business
buying a product subscribing to emails
whatever your goals are and I've been
tracking those conversions you can look
back all the way to the getting the
process the keywords someone used their
search queries in an engine and decide
what words are useful what ads are best
for you so that you look at the whole
search process of how someone searching
and then bidding appropriately or
deciding up to bid at all based upon
these metrics and so when you start
advertising you're going to realize a
few things you have your goals as a
marketer a searcher has their set of
goals and the search engine has their
set of goals and so thinking of this
alignment is important between where you
align goals versus just follow policies
so for instance a search results starts
because someone did a search right that
initiate the entire search result page
now you consider a search engine their
goal is to make sure this person has
such a good experience they want to
search again the goal isn't yours their
goal is the best results possible so
it's a repeat searcher now as a marketer
of course your goal is conversions you
want to put a relevant offer in front of
that searcher so they become a customer
different goals now the the actual
search the person who started this
process they don't care what your goal
is they don't care the search engines
ago they're saying who's going to answer
my question and so we think about this
you need to align your goals with the
searcher there are the ones at the
end of the day convert and become your
customer but the engines dictate how
this ecosystem works so you have to play
with in the policies the search engines
things we'll talk about throughout the
video series and make sure you're in
their policies but from a goal alignment
standpoint if you can make the search
you're happy they become customers this
fits in with why you're advertising in
the first place to increase revenues and
get customers now we look at search and
we look at overall activities online the
most common activity is usually email or
some sort of social communication number
two is usually search most of the others
are there transactional or informational
so for instance common activities are
getting weather information getting
hobby information this is information
retrieval activities over the past 20
years we've turned from looking at
yellow pages and trade magazines using
search and so by looking at where people
are getting relevant content you can
decide how you want to use search then
as your advertising vehicle but there's
someone looking for hobby information
and maybe it's gardening the most common
hobby in the US and therefore you put
out information about how to start a
garden and you can monetize even those
information queries to a plot of
transactional courage with someone is
actively trying to buy a product so
we're looking at how people are
searching what they're doing online and
then how you fit into the entire
ecosystem you can advertise users
through a lot of different activities
they're doing online now one of the most
important concepts to think to keep in
mind as you're advertising the search is
that advertising is not advertising when
it's information so for instance as
people will really resistant to ads we
don't want someone to tell us what to do
all the time however that's often
interruptive based advertising with
search someone's looking for a product
so when you're giving them information
it's not
ads you're helping them so let's just
put this in a real life example for a
second let's say that i'm currently in
san francisco and then i'm a 49ers fan
and let's just say this weekend the
49ers are playing the seahawks up in
seattle and so we're thinking i'd be a
great weekend let's go hop in the car
drive up to seattle and watch the game
will make a weekend out of it so we get
in the car on saturday morning we start
driving billboards past the spire
everyone sees billboards all over the
interstate their ads who cares we don't
care about these ads right now a couple
hours past was well we're kind of
getting hungry no we didn't need first
where should we stop and get breakfast
billboards aren't ads right now we're
looking for them to find out what our
options are there currently information
now we stop we heed we get out a car
what not we get back in the keep driving
Seattle and who cares billboard rats now
when you think of search someone's
looking for that information therefore
search ads are not ads when you're
helping someone make a decision so don't
think of searches gimmick advertising I
think it is you're helping a customer or
potential customer fine with it looking
for in return they give you money for it
that's a great ecosystem of advertising
because you're helping them make
decisions so with search advertising
they give this informational based
advertising you help them out given them
what the information they need they help
you up becoming a customer so just want
to recap how we search you'll be
searched to learn answers to questions
that's why we searched in the first
place so an ad can help answer the
question tell user they can get their
information from you right these are ads
in essence but the really pieces of
information and now that ad often the
first brand experience with someone
leads to your landing page the first
page summon sees after clicking on add
going to your website your first brand
will experience on your site when that
landing page connects the user to what
they searched for initially
antennas in fur contains information
about the ads that's when conversion
rates go up so search non eruptive
someone's already looking for
information so when your help people get
answers to their questions that's when
your conversions go up and paid search
becomes an incredibly profitable channel
for your business
you